Kim you and taylor swift's still a beef
with taylor after all that went down
knows all right over it good and have
you two had any communication or you
just feel like we've all moved on no I
feel like we've all moved on but as Kim
really moved on from her feud with
Taylor Swift are you ready for it Taylor
has been teasing the dates April 26 on
her Instagram for days but then Kim
tweeted this announcing a new fragrance
with her sister Kylie releasing on 12
April 26
of course Swifties went nuts tweeting to
Kim things like we will be streaming ts7
lead instead and isn't that the same day
as t s7 is it cooler said o
interestingly enough Kim has deleted the
tweet making people think she and Kylie
are changing the release dates of their
fragrance I don't understand how you
could not fangirl about that but Kim did
just share this explaining the lunch had
changed citing production issues with
their bottles but still Taylor and Kim's
history goes way back when Kanye
released this song they claimed Taylor
signed off on the lyrics then changed
her mind they knew it was gonna be
controversial the camera crew filmed him
speaking to Taylor and got their whole
conversation so I think he definitely
really you know cared about how she felt
I think she got freaked out by the
reaction and all of a sudden she flipped
[Music]
after that tailor was inundated with
snake emojis she seemingly addressed the
situation in Elle this year quote I
can't tell you how hard I had to keep
from laughing every time my 63 foot
inflatable Cobra named Karen appeared on
stage and it would be nice if we could
get an apology from people who bully us
but maybe all I'll ever get is the
satisfaction of knowing I could survive
it and thrive in spite of it now we wait
until April 26
[Music]